alors avez-vous tué quelqu'un
de mes propres mains
non non je n'ai jamais tué personne nous
marchions tous nous étions vraiment de votre
côté
et de quel côté était ce
euh
du côté du peuple vietnamien
les gens du nord des gens
du sud
enfin tous  d'entre eux, je suppose que
nous nous ressemblons tous après tout,
je veux dire que je pourrais être Vietcong pour tout ce que vous
savez un espion
comment sauriez-vous que
je ne le suis pas bien sûr J'aime l'Amérique
[Musique]
ici en Amérique, nous accueillons des gens comme
vous
[Musique  ]
Bien sûr que vous êtes des réfugiés,
et si je vous disais
que j'étais
un communiste
sous couverture, bienvenue dans le monde de
l'espionnage, nous
vous avons envoyé en Amérique pour que vous puissiez être
notre mode,
mais qu'est-ce qui doit émouvoir quand il
est soudainement projeté au soleil ce  c'est du
contre-espionnage parce qu'on est
ici qu'est-ce que tu caches
je ne sais pas si je
peux
continuer comme ça
d'accord,
je pense que vous êtes tous un homme sérieux, vous seriez
un espion terrible